- Gonna ride till the
wheels come off, baby.
- [Manny] Lowrider bicycles
is a special everything.
Special frame, special
wheels, special paint.
Everything is special.
The bicycles we make, is made with love
because it's with our hands.
(funky music)
- [Voiceover] You know those bikes Snoop
and countless other
rappers rode around in,
you know the ones that
ooze that West Coast style?
Lowrider bikes.
Low to the ground,
chromed out, gold-plated.
They're an extension of
lowrider car culture.
And they all started here.
- I am the godfather of
the lowrider bicycles.
When I was 10 years old,
I used to fix all the
bicycles in the neighborhood.
I always dreamed with
a motorcycle and a car,
but since I was too small and no money,
so I put my mind into bicycles.
- [Voiceover] A mainstay in
Compton and West Coast culture,
these iconic bikes were actually
first created in Mexico.
- [Voiceover] I brought
the lowrider to California
in early 80's.
- [Voiceover] And soon after,
locals took notice of
the shiny, swaggy rides
hanging in his shop.
- When I start making
bicycles in this place
people come and they say hey, can
you make me one of those?
And then they spread,
and now we have customers
from all over the world.
- This is one of Manny's
creations right here.
He's almost a pack-rat,
he put everything on here.
He blew my mind when he
put it on there for me.
- [Manny] It's completely different
than the regular bike,
in the way they look, in the
way they drive, it's a art.
People dream, and we
make the dream come true.
(funky music)